we're live chat you we can thank you
thank you very much well welcome uh
fellow councillors and
members of the public to the full
council meeting of torres district
council on monday the 10th of august
at 2020. we start with
apologies um
have we got any apologies i know we're
going to do the register in a minute but
any apologies yes chair we have three
apologies
counsellor dart
thank you very much for that so now
we're going to go through the list
for attendance yeah we've got councillor
harding steve harding
right that's another one anymore
right so we'll do the attendance then
thank you sandra
thank you chair councillor belton yes
i'm here
chancellor brenton president councillor
bright
president councillor brown
president councillor bushby
thank you councillor cottle hunkin
present chancellor craigie
yeah councillor ford
here that's legab
here councillor hackett present
councillor haynes president councillor
heart
i didn't know sorry that was an apology
councillor hawkins
yeah i'm here councillor hick
counselor heck
counselor langford present
counselor laws present penciller leather
present counselor lock present
pencil mcgough yeah
councillor mackenzie president
chancellor manley president
angela newton
councillor pennington here
pencil watson yes
and councillor wiseman i'm here
thank you very much councillors so we
moved to item
two which is uh council minutes and i
propose to
go through both those sets of minutes at
the same time
and then at the end when we vote on them
if sandra would do a sort of double
line so you can either say um for
and abstain or abstain them for for the
two meetings so this 22nd of june and
then the 27th of july
so start with the 22nd of june on page
four
chair councillor haines chair councillor
haynes has got his hand up
uh
on the minutes on i don't know whether
it's page four page seven i don't know
which
pages are going on actually probably
page four
page four on the 22nd of june
yeah thank you okay which one is that in
um yeah it's not it's
um matters arising
um i had a question
about um
yeah i had a question about um
having a special meeting um regarding
the local plan
yes and it's minuted that you were to
discuss it with
councillor haynes um um
to discuss with councillor haims items
for discussion at a special meeting and
ways forward
um i'm a little bit disappointed i've
phoned you twice now and to ask you
about this and i still haven't had a
response well because i've been in
negotiations with
um stephen hurst because it doesn't
involve just us it involves north devon
as well okay
the district plan it is in hand thank
you but
the progress is painfully slower i might
have to say
but it is it hasn't been forgotten and
uh you know i think your notice emotion
later on will uh
will emphasize that okay yeah that's
just one more
one more thing um in the minutes my
paper minutes
the um voting record is tabulated
at great length every time a decision is
taken i just wonder whether there's some
other way in which we
could record the votes which doesn't
waste so much paper
maybe just list all those name people
run them on the people who approved and
and then list the ones maybe not take up
so much
it's just uh i'm afraid there's no other
way of doing it because
it's a a legal document and
therefore the votes we have to record
the votes because it's done through
electronically um and it has to be set
out in that way so
any member of the public can see who
voted not just by sheer numbers
they can do that when we're in we can do
that when we're
in a full council meeting in
live because a member of public can see
who's voted which way
but as they're not privy to that at the
moment we have to do it this way
all right thank you thank you so page
four
page five
page six page seven
page eight page nine
page ten pages
christy which page page nine page nine
okay it's item six
um you see there that uh i did bring up
the subject of the burwood planning
application oh yes
its impact on our local plan um since
then of course
uh this government has now come out with
another load of nonsense
without planning uh i think it's the
technical term nonsense
um i have asked our planning officers to
prepare a digest
of what this actually means for
councillors in each ward
and i've asked for it to be circulated
to every council and i just thought i'd
better let councillors know in case they
wonder why it suddenly turns up
okay thank you for that thanks for
playing
councillor pennington has his name up
his hand up his wheelchair
answer pension thank you chair just
above that
um you you asked for a diary to be
coordinated i just wonder where that's
got to
chairman uh i don't know what the
officers have received
so far um i will um
check on that thank you for reminding me
on that one because um
this various officers will have received
or been involved in various aspects
aspects of the coronavirus all right
thank you
thank you that was on page
10 page 11 age
twelve page three jones chair
yes which item please it's
item eight on page twelve at the bottom
we resolved that um i'm sorry it's just
on the page 13 we resolved that
these would be re-examined regarding the
remote meetings procedure and a revised
set would be brought for the next full
council and we haven't had a revised set
of those so i was just wondering what
was happening with that
thank you we've got an item on the
agenda uh later on
which the district solicitor will be
talking to
which is to do with um the remote
um procedures okay
okay i'm trying to find out which which
number it is here on there
number eight item h a much remote
meeting here you're
number eight so we'll have some update
on that thank you
uh councilman golf
thank you mr chairman has you forgotten
that the page again there
about the uh cancer jones just raised
there it was supposed to be a
written document to folk out so not a
verbal update
so we're going to actually read what
it's going to be
chad you want me to answer that yeah if
you would
um the reason there's no uh update or no
updated set
of procedure notes is because they're no
longer required
as cut the council is now operating its
normal committee
procedure and normal meetings so
other than us operating virtually
all the other items put forward in those
draft documents at the time and no
longer required
all right okay thank you so so we are
following
the correct procedures thank you page
12. oh sorry we've done that page 13
page 14 page 15
page 16 page 17
age 18 age
19 age 20
age 21 age 22
age 23 i'll now go on to
july the 27th
page 24. page 25
page 26 page 27
page 28. age 29
age 30 page 31
age 32 page 33
834 page
35
page 36 page 37
838 page 39. i better move those minutes
would somebody second that please
happy to second castle thank you
councillor hackett
so now we go to the vote on these and if
we
take them both together as i said at the
outcome at the outset rather if you
say you know four for both or abstain
from one if you weren't there or
whatever
um so that sounds good you can do two
ticks
or ticking across whatever sandra is
that is that all right
can you deal with that yes thank you
chair that's okay
thank you very much we'll start off
sorry chair sorry no you carry on
cancel about 10. yeah four for both
councillor brenton four for both
councillor bright four for both
councillor brown poor for two thank you
councillor bushby
all right four for both thank you
councillor christy four for both
that's the clark
sorry councillor craigie i didn't catch
what you said abstain on the first one
because i wasn't there and four for the
second one
thank you councillor ford
abstain four
sorry hawkins it's
four for both
chancellor hicks four for both
james all for both chancellor jones
four for both councillor langford
four for both councillor laws
all for both penciller leather
four for both counselor lock
four for both pencil and mcgrath
four and four councillor mackenzie
yeah i'm for both councillor manly
yes for both councillor newton
four for both councillor pennington
or for both councillor watson fought for
both
and councillor wiseman or the first and
abstain the second
thank you
sorry chuck can i just clarify just one
point it was one
it was one proposal for both sets of
minutes
and so we can't separate the votes out
so
um those who have abstained for one and
four for the other it will have to be an
abstention
because we haven't done a separate vote
for the minutes
okay all right if that's all acceptable
fair enough
well hopefully that saved a bit of time
councillors and and councillor haynes
should save a bit of paper as well
so it's a win-win situation i hope so
item three then is public contributions
and um
we have one i believe is that right from
the atlantic wrecking center
uh okay i think chair that's right uh
steve hurst i think it's got the uh
written contribution from them
i have cheerleader are you ready and
i'll read it out thank you very much
okay uh so it's from atlantic record
center
charity support statement august 20 um
in support of council language notice a
motion
um it reads we are a charitable
organization and we opened our doors to
the community in 2015 when we had six
floodlit outdoor tennis courts and a
temporary clubhouse
in january 2018 we opened our indoor
sports hall with four indoor tennis
courts and three badminton courts
on opening we had around 80 users per
week
and currently we are now over 1 100
weekly visitors
since opening our outreach program has
been through a period of significant
development
and is thriving with a multitude of
users in addition
once completed we hope to add one
additional badminton court ten table
tennis
tables two squash courts two fitness
studios a gym a bar
and caf cafeteria change rooms toilets
offices and a car park additionally it
will provide specialist immune
amenities for disabled individuals
through the provision of a changing
places facility
the facts atlantic rocket center is a
community charitable
accessible affordable and inclusive for
the whole community in torridge district
it's working with schools all over the
district from heartland rosary torrenton
appledore northern and biddeford 16
primary
that includes acct a partner
organization and three secondary
is working with two sen schools lampard
school and pathfield school
provides sessions for three linked
behavioral schools peter's marlin school
shoreline academy and wave mat a
household four can join from as little
as eight pounds per month
that's just two pounds each
anyone can book a tennis or badminton
court and pay and play without joining
as member
our three badminton courts are currently
available 30 hours per week and are
running a near full capacity
our four indoor courts are currently
fully booked most weeknights pre-covered
our six outdoor courts are extremely
busy since reopening following lockdown
arc runs a full range of sessions and
classes from cardio tennis walking
tennis tots tennis
learning disability tennis and badminton
from all ages from
3 to 85 no limit arc
runs a range of competitions for all
ages with our
flagship event in may attracting over
300 entries from the southwest and
beyond
arc is fully accessible and works
closely with the clients of northern
caretrust
a partner organization and once every
month they run an inclusive festival for
anyone
with any form of disability from
learning disabilities to physical
arc runs six open and free community
days
every year with 221 people attending
each event on
average arc is working with many
community groups
torridge u3a devon learning recovery
services
exercise for mental health scouts groups
and cabs
3230 children access free tennis every
year
12 920 children have experienced tennis
since the center opened in 2015.
arc now has over 650 members and over
330 people
on weekly coaching programs over 1112
people
visit the center every week arc have
over 50 volunteers who work with three
with the three full-time staff and nine
part-time staff once completed and fully
open arc will generate at least 15 new
jobs for members of the local community
and are planning on running a mentoring
and volunteers volunteering scheme
to help get disadvantaged and unemployed
people
the skills and experience they need to
get into the workplace
we have raised over a thousand pounds to
provide a defib
which is available to the community of
cadstown
we have raised over 20 000 to install
a changes placed changing places
disability toilet
and changing facility which will be open
to the whole community
irrespective of them using arc
we have already raised over 2.9 million
pounds
but we now really need the last 100 000
pounds section 106
money to enable us to finish the phase
build in 2020.
we've just received 375 000 pounds
from the lta but we still need 100 000
pounds from tdc
to complete the current phase which
should see us
almost fully operational with m e
changing rooms toilets gym and car park
completed
without this many will not be able to
open any of these additional facilities
this community this community facility
will be an asset which will benefit the
mental health and well-being of whole
torridge district and at this very
difficult period of time it has never
been
more needed also terrig torridge health
are extremely keen to start social
prescribing of exercise and leisure
activities
so we need to finish this project as
soon as possible
but we cannot do that without your help
that's it jim thank you very much steve
well you've heard that i hope we
gathered all the information from that
because
it comes up later with the um notice of
motion from councillor langford
so now we move on to uh declarations of
interest
uh you know the procedure for that by
now
uh raise it when the item is um
your interest when the item is raised
and then five is agreement between
part one and two and we do have to vote
on this but uh
um hopefully the next council meeting
will be able to
amend our constitution present
constitution
to uh exclude this particular item
until we get to the part where we do
vote to go to part two but in the
meantime we have to go through
the agreement of agendas part one and
two
so sandra if you would um please um
go through the list again check can we
have a proposal in second to please
i propose that we go that that is i'll
second it yeah
i'll say watson so proposing seconded so
okay thank you chair councillor bowton
at four councillor brampton
or penciller bright
penciller brown or councillor bushby
or penciller christie or
cancer clark or chancellor cotterhunken
or penciller craigie
or councillor ford
poor counselor gab
for penciller hackett
or penciller haims or
pencilla hawkins or
penciller hicks or
penciller hudson or penciller harley
or chancellor inch
for councillor james for cancer jones
or pencilla langford for
penciller laws or penciller leather
or penciller lock or
mcgoff or mackenzie
poor penciller manly paul
councillor newton or cancer pennington
or
that's unanimous thank you chair thank
you thank you sandra
item sticks uh matters brought forward
um
two things firstly there's a strong
possibility that the next full council
meeting scheduled for the end of
september
will be shifted to the first uh monday
of october that isn't confirmed yet
and the second item is to do with the
uh last council meeting where uh
individuals
names were um mentioned in debate
members of the public and it was raised
by i think councilman golf
uh i just need to tell you councillors
that uh
you run a risk of mentioning
members of the public in the country but
we do have a
degree of privilege as do mps
but there are there is always at risk
that uh a member of public might take
umbrage of what you've said and and
pursue it so uh
you know as i say you have to weigh up
the balance between what is the interest
of democracy or
the public interest against the uh
privacy or the
reputation of an individual i say no
more
it is your judgment thank you and now we
move to item
seven answered questions under procedure
rule
nine a nine and i think uh councilman
mcgoff has
submitted a question which you can see
in front of you
and uh councillor mccoff you're
obviously entitled to a uh
supplemental question
thank you very much mr chairman um i
can't actually see
oh i know the response of it anyway the
answer there right um
unfortunately due to the cover situation
it's putting us back
a hundred pesos back isn't unfortunately
i've really got much to say about it
just like to see it implemented as soon
as possible wants to play strategies
actually up and running
thank you well thank you councilman
mcgough i'm i'm sure you'll keep us
our feet to the fire on that one i hope
you do because i think it's a very very
important
um uh item to raise up and i think we
could
enjoy set a set a standard for other
local authorities because i've been to a
few play parts of my dear grandchildren
and
you don't see them so but i'm sure
there'll be a
use for them thank you for that
and now we come to eight which is um
remote meetings procedures and i think
uh
stacy doria has got uh some words of
wisdom on that one
thank you yes thank you chair
um as um steve hurst alluded to earlier
i haven't brought the procedurals back
to full council tonight
predominantly because we're no longer in
the emergency committee cycle
and we are back to our normal pleased to
say that we are back to our normal
committee schedule and therefore we're
working under our normal
constitution right
now how about the um making an amendment
then for the next meeting
to uh not duplicate the agreement
between
part one and two can that be done
yes chair the um amendments as a whole
uh to the constitution are coming
forward
to uh september's full council so we can
add that on as well
right oh good right thank you for that
uh of course once we get back to a
normal procedure
please called that be soon you know then
it wouldn't rise in any case but
thank you uh so now we go on to
item nine the draft strategic plan and i
think that uh councillor james is going
to lead on that
thank you chair um just very briefly the
report says it all
we we started out last autumn in doing
our strategic planning
um we were ready to go for consultation
early in march
or towards the end of march when
obviously coronavirus
uh sets back on everything so what we've
done is we've made a few modifications
and i was just reading the report
i can't remember what it was i should
have highlighted them but basically
the um we've updated it very slightly to
deal with the situation we're in
in so much as obviously climate change
is very important
and we need to be looking at working
with partners
with talk of uh devolution and all sorts
of things going on
so basically it's really accepting what
we've is in front of you
so we can go up for consultation and
then we can set a boat
once that comes back we can set about
actually putting some meat on the bones
to deliver what we want to do
within the strategic plan so i think
the report says just simply to
page 42. so go ahead and publish it
yeah yeah so i'll move that's what we do
all right secondary for that please
somebody thank you councillor watson
um
steve harris yep chair the only [ __ ] i
was going to add to councillor james
alluded to the this minor modification
so um on the the front page on page 43
in respect of the pandemic we obviously
currently within
we've added a word so where it used to
say communities and housing we've added
communities health and housing in there
on the second page on page 44
um the the heading of the third column
is now actions by us and in partnership
reflecting what
councilor james just referred to as
working with others you'll see we've
also
added the theme her health as well
and in the actions by us we've now
included an action which is the
in communities health and housing the
second one up from the bottom there
which starts adopt the devon
joint health and well-being strategy and
deliver the action plan
we've now included in their work with
dcc
to expand cycleways and the footpath
network within the district
reflecting of some of the the
improvements that have come out
i guess we we initially thought that it
might need a bit more
modification following this uh period
we've gone through
but ultimately whilst um
pandemic may have changed our starting
position and
delivered some opportunities uh the
aspirations of the council
remain largely the same and to deliver
all these things for our residents
the only other item i guess to refer to
is the
in the same block communities health and
housing
around implementing the housing delivery
strategy and investigating the
feasibility of becoming a direct housing
provider
obviously that's later on the agenda for
councillor haynes's notice of motion
but just to say we've started some work
in that area
the leader and high councillor james and
i've had a help
meeting with the lga this afternoon to
start discussing
how we might seek to looking at those
housing options for the future
chair that's all i had thank you very
much
steve so what do you now need to vote
on the recommendation on page 42 which
is
the yeah you've got a few counsellors
with their hands up right
please who's first councillor jones
mr jones thank you chair i say this is a
very um
very interesting read it's obviously
only an a4 piece of paper so i do wonder
why it's taken so long to
come back to us but there we are the
only thing i'd like to point out
is under the section our environment our
future
um there's the second down
on the actions by us
part of the table it says about ensuring
that climate change and
biodiversity is the heart of our
governance and processes
if i recall rightly when we had the
debate on climate change we
declared the emergency and uh torridge's
position within
we actually made it a separate thing
that we would have a further report into
biodiversity
to learn more about that rather than
just committing to something which no
one um
seemed to really be sure about and that
was that was agreed and i don't think
we've had any
uh consultation with our farming
communities on this so i'm just a bit
concerned to see that it's um slipped
back in despite the fact that it was
separated off in the first since
thank you well this is obviously a draft
consultation
document so hopefully people will
respond to what they see
when this is when this is put out to the
public and um
respond accordingly but we wait and see
uh who else was it um counselor
counselor hunking chair thank you yes
sir
hello sorry and i was just wondering if
i could propose a very small amendment
um where it says so communities health
and housing section
where it says reduce health inequalities
while promoting healthy lifestyles i
would propose that we
change that to reduce health
inequalities while promoting
active and healthy lifestyles so just
adding in
active and to that sentence
i'd be happy to second that chair thank
you
am i allowed to propose a small
amendment uh absolutely
um sorry i'm not like it's happy to
second
right thank you council hackett uh so
that's just the additional word of
say again please literally two words so
active
and so we promote active and healthy
lifestyles
rather than just promoting healthy
lifestyles
right thank you so when when we go to
the vote i'll include that
uh uh amendment into
the vote if the mover doesn't object to
that
counselor james no no objection right
okay and the second of course
right okay so um any more mr walters
yeah counselor lock chair i'm not on
page 44 local economy and
second bullet point down develop count
town centres and the developed town
centers then it says at the rural
offering i don't quite understand under
what umbrella what comes under
rural offering it seems rather wide
today and i'd like that rephrase
but i can't think of anything suitable
in time
right rural dimension will not do it
who wrote this right can i come in their
chair
yeah i've got my hand up right okay
okay right on the two things councillor
jones
um the biodiversity stuff coming out of
exeter university has been held up
obviously because
coronavirus i had an invite it must be
about two weeks ago
to inform me that um i represent
um ruby country and the rural issues to
do with biodiversity
on that group and they informed me they
were hoping to get the group going again
shortly
and they would be informing me as soon
as that's
um come to vote so it's just been held
up a little bit
but we are on that um and on coaster
locks
point about uh rural dimension
i've been having some discussions about
whether we should be looking we're doing
all three tones are being looked at
regeneration and
and everything like that and whether the
raw economy
should be looked at um so that we can
perhaps have a group looking at what we
can do to improve
as it says there somewhere um raw
offerings
and that would be cycleway walking
um rural industries all that sort of
thing
so we've only started thinking about it
last week
and hopefully this will go to
consultation
you can all come back with your comments
on it along with everybody
else and those comments we will absorb
into it and bring back to you again
so that we can just get on and get
something delivered
okay thank you thank you
council applied chair mr bright
thank you chair i was also going to
propose a small amendment
um to the local economy section on the
first page
um under the section it says uh promote
aspiration and growth to create a
vibrant economy with
quality jobs just wondering if we can
add uh create a vibrant
um culture and thriving a common
economy with their quality jobs just to
encompass the arts as well is also quite
a big industry which is
definitely struggling at the minute so
you want to add
create um yeah
create a vibrant uh
create a vibrant culture and thriving
economy with quality jobs
yeah all right yes okay
so that's uh no problem
chair all right no problem with that
all right sandalwood windows so any any
further
amendments council hayes
yeah just to come back on councillor
jones's comment about biodiversity
um i i thought thought when he
talked about it when we uh when we voted
on the climate emergency
stuff that uh i was slightly puzzled
he's not aware of what biodiversity
means given all the
stuff in the press um in the media about
the
huge decline in wildlife um secondly
i seem to remember we talked about
biodiversity at the review workshops we
had earlier in the year
and it came up very prominently
particularly on planting trees and
things
so i hope that this will be continuing
to be included in the uh
consultation in this uh strategic review
thank you thank you well as councillor
james pointed out this is the
sort of bone spare bones if you are
going out to the public
and of course yourselves so that you're
perfectly entitled and encouraged to
respond and amend et cetera et cetera
when when it goes to the consultation
all right
uh councillor uh sorry uh john waters
there's another
another speaker councillor christie then
councillor bush speaker
all right councillor christopherson
thank you thank you can i just
talk about something on page 44 on the
our environment our future section
fourth bullet point down manage coastal
and flood defenses to meet the
challenges of the modern climate
now i've never heard it expressed that
way before and a
rough rule of fun if you want to see if
the word is suitable is to
use the opposite which would be
old-fashioned
uh could i suggest we change modern to
changing climate that's the reason
we're looking towards this it's a
changing climate and it isn't
necessarily what a lot of people think
uh we could actually get a lot colder
here in devon rather than warmer
so i think changing would be much better
and i think most people would recognize
what that means rather than modern
climate
all right no no problem again sir
all right thank you good thank you
council christie
and cancer bushby thank you chair
i'm again on page 44 under
our environment and future
on the top of that paragraph it says
relocate all waste and recycling
resources to one new modern
environmental
center i think that is a something which
should be a really high priority
for torridge particularly bearing in
mind you know where our existing depo is
in westcom which is you know totally uh
unacceptable for
anyone that's living there but um
can i then ask you to turn to page 49
on the uh bot on net borrowing go
towards the bottom
just above paragraph seven it says uh
four million pounds of external
borrowing relating to the new demo
has been delayed until future years so
does that mean
and that the um waste and recycling
depot has been put on the back burner
indefinitely um
okay join me to respond yes please
um that that particular item is in
relation to
2019-20 which is now passed
so that comment relates to last year
uh this is a backward look at that
particular report on page 49 it's a
backward looking report
reflection right okay so
so can we then is there any timeline as
to when
you know we're actually you know welcome
this new
waste and recycling depot into biddeford
as soon as possible chair
steve hurst got to answer that
um cha i think council allah has said it
uh precisely as soon as we've got a site
uh which we can accommodate we will
start uh the process
okay i have one other question sure yes
um same paragraph on our
environment on future down the bottom it
says
uh be responsive to erosion risks and
work in partnership
for the protection of our coastal assets
and communities
lobby for funding for the delivery of
linear defenses for westward on the
landfill site
now i can't stress enough the importance
of making this a high priority
particularly when you go to the top of
the page
under local economy where we seem to be
um
still wishing to pursue the borough's
visitor center
um the reason i say that there was a
report out in devon live three weeks ago
unfortunately i wasn't able to print off
a copy but i will endeavor to do so
where um another group of eminent
scientists similar to the ones that have
done
various reports on the boroughs of the
past um
state quite categorically that nolan
burrows
and that that area will not exist
in 2050 well that's only 30 years away
so you know they're obviously getting
their information somewhere so
you know if i i'd like to see our
officers that are
um dealing with us actually get a get a
copy of that report that what was on
dead in live
and you know look at the implications uh
you know that it throws up
thank you right thank you i'm sure the
officers taking out on board
um right so no other
contributions than uh john walter no no
no chair
right so we'll go to the vote now we've
it's been proposed and seconded
uh with those uh amendments which are
agreed by
the proposer so um sandra if you'd like
to start
thank you chair councillor bowton for
councillor brenton four councillor
bright
paul pence lebron four
councillor bushby against
councillor christy or
councillor clark or
councillor cottle hanken or
councillor craigie or
pencil of ford
chancellor ford four sorry
four thank you chancellor councillor gab
four chancellor hackett
paul penciller haims or
pencil hawkins or
counselor hicks
councillor hicks against
pencil hudson or
councillor harley or chancellor inch
or penciller james or
councillor jones or
councillor langford or
penciller laws or penciller leather
or councillor lock or
councillor mcgoff four councillor
mckenzie
four councillor manly
paul chancellor newton
paul councillor pennington or
chancellor watson or councillor wiseman
or that's 29
four and two against chair thanks sandra
well counselors will be interested to
see what response comes back from the
consultation
especially in these changing times could
be quite interesting
now we move on now to uh item 10 which
is the
annual report
those are found on pages 45 to 51
david's doing that is that right yes
that's correct chair
thank you david um the council is
required to report annual on its
treasury management
and the council undertakes its treasury
monument in line with the sit for code
or treasury management
just to summarize in order of priority
the
key components of our treasury
management policy are as follows the
security of our investments
so hence we only place our investments
with uk based
financial institutions with fitch f1
rating
liquidity so we just have sufficient
cash to carry out our day-to-day
business
and in the least priorities our return
on the investments
so i just want to touch on the impact of
colvid19
um with the bank of england announced a
base rate cut from 0.75
to 0.1 this will dramatically reduce the
amount of return the council will
receive on its temporary investments in
2020-21
and we're projecting currently to have a
reduction of 107
000 on how much income we'll get from
our treasury deposits
and we're expecting income from the
council's current bank account to be nil
however the bank of england base rate
looking backwards to the financial year
2019 actually had no impact on the
council's
finances because the bank of england
base rate cut was basically took place
at the end of march
so just some highlights from the 2019
performance
our average rate of return on the monies
that we lodged with our treasury
management
institutions was 1.05 percent
a slight improvement from 2018-19 which
was at 0.85 percent
in 2019 20 we got 116 000 pounds of
income
for the money that we deposited with
financial institutions
and we also received 31 000 pounds just
from money that was held in the
council's current bank account
on the 31st of march 2020
we had six million pounds lodged with
financial institutions which compares
with 10 million pounds lodged on the
31st of march
2019. during the year
we repaid 138 000 pounds of historic
public works loan board debt leaving was
a balance of historic public works loan
but debt of 814
000 pounds as of the 31st of march 2020.
in the report there are some prudential
indicators in the appendices i won't
intend to go through them
one by one but in very simple terms they
indicate whether the
council is funding its capital
expenditure in a prudent manner
and that it's its levels of borrowing
are affordable and i'll just go through
some
key highlights our 2019-20 capital
expenditure was funded from external
grants
primarily from the better care fund that
we receive by devon county council
for disabled facility grants on ecoflex
which is energy efficiency in people's
homes
or by our own air market by resources
that we'd previously set aside
we didn't fund any capital from
borrowing
all our borrowing reta pertains to
long-term historic public work loan
board debt
the council's authorized limit for
external debt
is 5.6 million and this has previously
been approved by
members and this pertains to the
provision of a new environmental center
and also additional homelessness
accommodation we quite clearly not
at this point got a new environmental
center so obviously we've not taken out
any borrowing
we have however purchased some
homelessness accommodation but we've
actually funded that from our existing
cash balances we haven't gone out and
got
new borrowing even though we have
approval to do so
there's something in the potential
indicators which would cause an
operational boundary of 1.8 million that
essentially means that we're allowed to
borrow for short-term cash flow purposes
we haven't exercised that option and
we're not intending to exercise that
option in the near future
with council only has which is
fortuitous foreign limited financing
costs essentially rating to the interest
charged on the public works loan board
debt
for 2019 20 we actually got
more income from our short-term
investments and money we lodged
with our financial institutions then
actually we paid in debt management cost
so in very simple terms the council is
not burdened by debt
the council's short-term and treasury
investments are all fixed term in nature
and at fixed interest rates so its
investments are not subject to
variations caused by interest rate
changes
happy to take any questions if there are
any share
thank you david that's um i do
understand what you're saying which is
pretty
unusual for me to understand what a
treasury officer said but
is that a reflection on steve
well of course it is oh yes
it usually has longer reports to report
on but never mind uh so
uh councillors got any questions from
anybody
no no right so that's uh
for noting i believe yes no
correct me if i'm wrong no no
recommendation sorry angela haynes just
got his hand up chair
councillor who haynes hey he's all right
yeah
go ahead thank you chad thank you for
the report
um i'm just wondering how um
our council's sustainable ethical policy
is
included in our um our strategy for
investments
um whether any work has been done to
disengage for
example from fossil fuels um i'd like to
know
really you know what action has been
carried out
recently there is that's the correct
council haynes there is a report going
to internal overview and scrutiny
on the 18th of august an ethical
investment report
which sets out some of the options and
issues that the councillors would have
to decide upon if they were to adopt
such a treasury management ethical
treasury management policy
thank you very much thank you right
um advice came from we've got council
mcgrath has got his hand up as well
go ahead famous chairman
uh page 46 is to touch upon the the
public loans board debt
um just in layman's terms can you just
explain again please david exactly what
that is
and how long do you see us clearing the
debt of 814
000 pounds please
public works loan board debt in simple
terms is the government
and the debt just dates back to historic
times when the council used to have
housing
sorry steve what does it just chop chess
it's not just
to do with the housing it's back when
the council was able to borrow money
against its capital program
when the government had a different
borrowing system where we were
given borrowing permissions called basic
credit approvals
which allowed us to borrow money and the
government
sorry allowed us to do that and so it
goes back
pre-2003 and we intend we will probably
pay off the debt i think it's in 2027
is the last um loan repayment
right sure guys just come back in that
quickly please
yeah okay i just want to thank the
officers there obviously
for the public watching this it's nice
to share that layman terms
exactly what it is and that is explained
very well so thank you
thank you
thank you chair i was just going to say
that the big
councils up and down the country give
the right to have a report as
as good as this thanks to uh
both the senior officers there stephen
and david
right yes noted thank you um i do
believe
this is only for noting so we don't need
to take a vote on this do we
no it's for noting is that correct no
we do need to take a vote we do need to
take a vote yes
right okay i'm sure there was a time
when noting meant noting and not
voting but there we go we have to vote
on it i presume has to do with our
remote um uh
method of uh operating at the moment is
that correct
yes chair yes okay all right well uh
sandra will go through the list again
please
thank you chair cancel about it
angela pennington has his hand up chair
sorry councillor pennington
point of order opportunity
there's two bullet points on the
recommendation are we voting to cover
both of them or is there two independent
votes
no i think it's a recommendation as with
the two notes on it okay
okay taking the guy thank you chair
thank you
right and councillor bowton
at four councillor brenton boar
pencil
councillor cottle hunkin or
pencil craigie or councillor ford
or penciller gab for
councillor hacketts four
ansel haynes or pencil hawkins
or penciller hicks
for cancer hudson
or chancellor hurley or
chancellor inch counselor james
or cancer jones or
councillor langford or pencil in laws
or ancillary leather or
pencil lock or cancer mcgoff
or chancellor mckenzie
or councillor manley or
chancellor newton or
chancellor pennington or chancellor
watson
or pencil wiseman or
that's unanimous chair thank you very
much sandra
all right so we moved to item 11 and
petitions
we don't have any and there we go to 12
notices motion the first one is a which
is from cancer haims
if you'd like to put forward your
reasons why
this should be supported councillor
james i'll ask for a second there
hey cher um just to remind this council
that
torridge has our councillors rather
torich has a target of 170 affordable
houses a year
but recently over quite a period has
only fulfilled
around 50 houses
it has been stated by our officers that
the outlook for provision of affordables
is bleak
because of failure to achieve the local
plans section 106 obligation of 30
percent
and because of the drop in the number of
sites being developed
resulting partly because of the economic
recession but also because of
the phenomenon of land banking given the
continued situation
likely increase in demand for affordable
housing and particularly social housing
for rent as we enter dar
times for the economy i'm asking for a
report which reviews the options for
this council
to achieve its affordable housing target
such a report should cover revisions the
local plan to tighten up on
policy on viability assessments and
other measures
in order to achieve the 30 requirement
but it should be recognized that
reliance and commercial developments to
deliver affordable housing
just isn't working satisfactorily
therefore other options should be looked
at such as direct and indirect provision
of affordable and social housing by this
council
and ways of securing land to deliver it
i recognize the new government proposals
concerning the planning system could
lead to abolition of section 106
housing requirements affordable housing
requirements
to be replaced by allocating a portion
of a levy on development but it has been
by no means clear that this will produce
more affordable housing
and there has been no indication that
social housing will be facilitated under
the new system
however i do suggest the report should
include an assessment of the
government's proposals as part of
providing a picture for this council
of the possible options available to it
i do realize finally that the council is
now operating under severe financial
constraints limiting its ability to
deliver services
given the continued and probably
increasing need for housing which is
affordable for a large section of local
people
in the torridge area an area which has
one of the lowest average incomes
in the uk it is the duty of this council
to investigate all possible ways in
which low-cost housing for purchase and
rent can be delivered
i'd ask for a seconder for my motion and
the councils to vote in favor of a
report to be
delivered ideally to the october full
council
while i recognize the forthcoming
strategic review encompasses the issues
i've covered
there is no clear deadline for delivery
of the aspirations in the review
so i suggest the report i'm asking for
will provide a basis for moving forward
thank you chair thank you thank you
councillor haynes i'm happy
to s um second your uh notice motion
right thank you uh councillor clark i
mean
i'm looking for guidance here as to
where this before we do that before
where this uh notice emotion will go
uh steve harris i think you um
yeah yeah sorry earlier earlier on i did
uh refer to
councillor james and i have a meeting
with the the
regional lga advisor to start helping
us look into what other councils have
done in this area
particularly the things around provision
of social housing
so we are looking at that already and
inevitably a report would have to be
brought back
to cnr with recommendations to full
council
because it will be such a quite a an
extensive piece of work
i should i'd say and in terms of the the
time scale
councillor aims referred to october
there's
i don't think there's any possibility of
being ready in that short space of time
given the extensive amount of work
required share
um obviously we shouldn't be debating
these notice of motion
anyway but um that's where uh
to be taken right so
in essence and councillor haines is
asking for a report which i you know
obviously fully support that
and um and that may not be doesn't
mention any notice of motion it
should be by october but nonetheless uh
as soon as we can
get it together because uh it is a very
very important issue and uh
we do need to uh give members of some
sort of idea of where we're going with
this
and before i ask anybody else to speak
up um
have we'll be asking the officers to
send out
a document a copy of which i have in my
possession
housing of the working classes act
1890 to 1909 which i think members will
find
interesting how much progress we have
made
he says tongue-in-cheek so
but it is a fascinating document but it
can be copied and
sent to each member and i propose that
will be will be done
so um yes we won't be
having a debate per se on this because
uh it will
the report will come back and that's
when we we will be debating it properly
i hope well we will so um we had another
um member wishing to speak is that right
councillor
gregory wasn't it councillor clark and
councillor christopher
clark who's the housing lead and uh and
then cancer craigie
uh council clark yeah i just wanted to
say that i was gonna second
councillor haines but you jumped in
before me which is fine
right um as we're all aware we are
either a low income or a no income area
yeah and pr housing provision
for young families and the like are
is very important so just
right to kenneth is that i'm supporting
councillor haines in this uh
motion yes well as i say we won't have a
debate about it now but we
we surely will uh councillor craigie
councillor christie chair sorry
councillor christie
i beg your pardon that's all right
council brenton um
yes i was going to second this as well
um i have actually read your
uh very old act there it is very
interesting but
um i sit on the planning committee and i
know the rest of the planning committee
members are all aware of this that
um on our recent application from
appledore
uh pitt hill we've got absolutely no
affordable homes at all
we talked last week about dad and hill
21 we're being offered and
i just want to go back to something i
said earlier in this meeting about the
burwood decision because
all of you are going to get speculative
applications now
from developers saying all torridge
haven't got the five-year
housing land we can put ours back in
and if they do torridge is going to be
in a real bind and i wonder for our
officers when they prepare this report
they could start looking
is it possible for torridge whenever
one of these applications comes forward
and quotes the fact we haven't got five
years land supply
can we look very carefully at the land
they're suggesting because what happens
now
is the developers come forward and they
say well we can only offer you
21 or in april case none at all
because the site conditions cost
so much and i think you should start
looking can we charge the developers
to do a site survey before their
application comes forward
because otherwise the planning committee
are just well
we can't do anything about it we just
told district valuer has found it
therefore that's it and i wonder if our
officers as part of this
could actually look at what's going on
could we actually start
charging developers to do site surveys
so they don't turn up a planning
application so
sorry it's so expensive to develop and
therefore you can't have any affordable
homes
because that's one of the big problems
we face thank you
thank you right so we should go to the
vote now on this
been proposed and seconded you do have
two more hands raised
ford and councillor craigie all right
sorry
it's up to you yeah councillor craig
here as long as it's
uh we don't want to get into a debate
here now
here and now too much detail in it i
don't i i did want to second the motion
right we could include in
in the report um providing our own
council housing and
also um looking at community land trust
right
here sorry you're breaking up but i
think the the two points you made were
uh
we could hear them so yeah sure the
officers take that on board
cancer yeah yeah hello chair
yes i can hear you good um just thanking
councillor christie for bringing that up
reference
uh the apple application because he's
absolutely
right we're not even following we ain't
showing any metal at all we're not even
following our own policies and quite
frankly
we should not be upon the committee
deciding how much profit
a developer can make or not make if
they've made an ill judgment
on a purchase of land to start with that
is not our concern
we break our own policy time and time
again and i do again thank councillor
christie
for actually highlighting it thank you
thank you right noted
and now we'll go to the vote then um
sandra
thank you thank you chair councillor
belton
at four councillor brenton
four councillor bright
paul councillor brown four
le bushby or cancer christie
or pencil clarke or
pencil cotton hankin or
pencil craigie or
counselor ford or penciller gab ball
ancella hackett or
penciller haims
waco
pencil hanes sorry i was muted um for
kenza hawkins or
penciller hicks
for cancer hudson
for cancer harley or
chancellor wrench or chancellor james
for canceling jones against
councillor langford for
penciller laws or penciller leather
or penciller lock or
hansel mcgough yes
chancellor mackenzie paul
councillor manly or councillor newton
or councillor pennington or
cancer watson
councillor wiseman dance
chair that's 29 4 and 2 against
thank you very much that's clearly
carried so that will
be noted so now we go to
a notice motion from councillor langford
would you like to
present your notification yes thanks
very much chair
um in 2016 the community charity
atlantic racket center was awarded 100
000 pounds section 106 grant
linked to the dad and hill development
while there is no guarantees with 100
with 106 funding it would have seemed a
fair reasonable expectation that they
would have received the money by now
some four years later
but unfortunately work on the dad and
hill development has not yet started
this has left that run atlantic racket
center in a very difficult situation
as they now require this grant to
complete the current phase of the
project
this includes the building's mechanical
and electrical systems to provide the
services required
to make the building functional
functional comfortable and safe
and the installation of the changing
rooms toilets and gym
when complete this initiative will be
self-sustaining and will make the
facility fully accessible to the whole
torridge community
at the moment they are operational but
at a reduced level
as a result they are currently not able
to offer the full range of leisure
activities and support facilities
required
to be a totally functioning community
leisure facility
that everyone within torridge can access
given the very challenging times we are
living in and the shortage of indoor
leisure facilities open and available
atlantic racket center charity is and
will be a key provider of leisure
activities
which will greatly benefit the mental
and physical health and well-being of
our local community
this is why i truly feel that we should
do all we can to support this project
and make this happen and why i've put
forward the notice of motion to explore
our options
to loan a hundred thousand pounds to
atlantic racket center charity
to enable them to complete the stage of
the project they've already done an
amazing job of raising funds of around
2.9 million
some of this funding has been gained
because of the expectation of the 106
grant allocated by tdc
currently contractors are back on site
but without our support they will not be
able to complete this project which i
feel will be a disaster for the people
of torres district
that's why i ask members to support this
motion for the sake of the physical and
mental well-being
of the people of torridge thanks very
much
thanks councillor langford i was second
there please i second that chap
oh second yeah
all right all right donald rusher once
never mind this will obviously
have to go to cnr because of the
financial implications so we won't be
debating it now
it will uh if if approved it will go to
cnr so
sandra if we go through the um they have
you do have three councils right well as
they should be points of order not
debating points
all right so cuttle hunk in first
put my hand up first i wanted to second
it as lead members
but councillor newton obviously got
there well done
daniel thank you and next one
counselor bushby answer bushby i thought
i have my hand up frost as well but
never mind all right okay
all right and the next one councillor
christie and then councillor mcgoff
christie yes just ask about the section
106 money
um when does that actually kick in how
many houses do they have to have built
at daddon hill before the money goes to
the iarc or comes back to us if we load
them now
right well i think that's a relevant uh
question um
steve harris can you answer that the
answer is
sorry i've got the answer to that chair
how have you
all right which is
yeah thanks j yeah i'll come in there
then
um prior to the occupation of the 15th
first 151st
dwelling then then they've got to pay
the
contribution over well that'll be in
phase two
of the development we've not seen we've
only just dealt with phase one which is
a
hundred and thirty dwelling so you
you're a few quite a few years away yet
from getting that money
right yeah well that's a fault of the
system isn't it really but there you go
um was there some other person
counselor mcgoff and then councillor
mcgoff thank you very much mr mine's
just a
point involved for illegal side of
things um
as the motion reads um i i'm in support
and emotion but in the financial
implications of the council
are we subsidizing the 106 monies
right i don't know is that actually
legal from torres to do so
that's a legalization i'd like to
clarity on please
well if you can't answer that now it'll
have to go to cnr for them to determine
that
chair that's that's why the report the
notice motions written that way so we
will look at all those options
as part of the report going to see now
thank you
uh who's the last one counselor lock
chair
council lock yeah um i know you
shouldn't ask questions just one quick
one i did some homework then it went on
the charity commission website
and looked at the accounts of the
atlantic record center
and the last page says if atlantic
bracket center fails to complete the
build of the center
the grants received from sport england
totaling 485
000 pounds will be repayable on demand
right so i think that's a very important
point to remember
well when was that when was that made
when was that report made was that
pre-covered i
presume well that that was on their end
of year accounts
ended 31st december 2019.
yeah well i think uh i think the world
has moved on a bit since then don't you
especially over the well-being and
physical activity business because of
covet but
error what do i know um however i'm
going to take the vote now
so um sandra if you would please
yes chair counselor bangtan
four penciller brenton boar
councillor bright or counselor brown
or councillor bushby
or councillor christie or
cancer clark or councillor cotton hanken
or penciller craigie
or penciller ford or
penciller gab paul councillor hackett
or pencilla haims or
[Laughter]
your bucket
you need to unmute councillor hicks
please
bore pencil hudson
paul
[Music]
against penciller langfood
or pencil laws
you need to unmute cancel the laws
please
sorry oh well it soon be christmas
pencil leather or
cancer lock four
councillor mcgrath in support
councillor mackenzie
for councillor manly or
councillor newton or cancer pennington
or pencil watson
poor pencil
that's 34 and one against chair
thank you that's clearly carried so
we'll go to cnr thank you
so now we come to c which is uh from
cancer four but before uh
council report begins uh i can recall
when i was first on this council many
years ago when uh
your father councillor ford was a
councillor he did propose when we had
this jet ski
problem decades ago that um
we float a a rope across the river to uh
bring them down but uh i don't suppose
you're proposing that now but
nonetheless because it's a complicated
thing this two will have to go to cnr if
approved
because we're getting into the realms of
maritime law
highly complicated thanks to henry viii
but there we are
we have to live with that so cancer ford
if you'd like to
put your proposal forward and we'll ask
them for a
yeah um trying to keep this brief
actually because it says what it is and
actually
there is an issue here where i'm
actually not you know i'm making that
quite clear i'm not trying to be a
killjoy
and stop the use of jet skis on the
estuary of the river unfortunately
because things have got busier and
busier and some people
not all but some don't even abide by the
rules before they even launched the
thing reference foundation trailers
parking in the house zone
this needs to be addressed this is a
fact because actually in a minute
somebody's going to end up i think
with possibility of injury a loss of
life it's actually chaos okay there i do
know what i'm talking about i don't tell
people the sticks i didn't milk a cow or
share a sheep but i could roll a boat
before i could probably walk i know what
i'm on about
it cannot be kicked in the the canyon
and if you look at your map anyway
there's three
other three other launching points
actually two in north devon one
bank end and i'm proposing that
biddeford almost specifically
is used for jet skis because you've got
almost
a little used car park opposite i've got
photographs so they
i've done me work here and unlike uh
councillor mcgoff when he uses the word
plethora a greek origin means abundance
i have got abundance of evidence and
which i'm quite happy to therefore take
the cnr when it goes there
i'm hoping my fellow councilor will
second this uh
from from representing outdoor
councillor haynes and with that i'll
leave it
thank you uh secondary then please
lehanese has got his hand up chair
right you gonna second it councillor
haynes yes chair it's
um it's an ongoing problem it's been
going on for years and
so far no no way has been found to
tackle it given that uh appledore
appears to be a free-for-all
port um i i welcome the opportunity for
cnr to just to debate
this and discuss the possible options by
laws or whatever but it needs
it needs looking at urgently thank you
yes well i look forward to that debate i
can tell you
so we'll go to the vote now cassandra
please chair chair you do have three
counsellors
they need to be points of order please
not part of the debate
yes councillor mckenzie answer mckenzie
i believe this is the notes of motion to
be slightly flawed and as much as i
believe that the jet skis cannot
come up the river beyond the new bridge
um
so launching from bank end is not really
an option um somebody will correct me if
i'm wrong
i'm sure well it's true what you're
saying councilor mackenzie there was a
mapped out area
for the estuary as to what activity
could take place where and when
but that will be uh brought up i hope at
cnr
thank you for that uh next one
councillor clark and then councillor
christie
answer clark yeah hi um
as a qualified safety boat officer i
just wondered
do we have is there no provision on the
river at all
for the provision against speed
right vessels there was
there was i say there was i don't know
if it's still in force and and how
impossible that is but like say
these do we uh come out of the washing
um
in seeing our debate okay all right yeah
noted um councilor christie
i'm just going to add to your memory of
uh councillor philip ford
it wasn't just a rope across the river
he did offer that if torridge bought a
shotgun he'd actually shoot them
i try to be a bit more liberal than that
yes well uh council christie those back
in the good old days when uh
when when as i say men were men if you
we won't go any further with that one
right so we're now going to go to the
vote sandra if we can um
bushby
i'm going to abstain
councillor ford four penciller gab
for councillor hackett
or pencil or
it's not hawkins
or counselor hicks
four three it's the hudson
against councillor james
or councillor jones
pencil langford or
penciller laws or pencil leather
or penciller lock or
pencil mcgough what a wonderful word
that was counselor thought i'm for it
counselor mackenzie against
counselor manly
chancellor newton or
cancer pennington or hencella watson
or councillor wiseman against
that is
25 4 4 against
and two abstentions chair
thank you very much sandra so that's uh
carrie that will go to cnr
so now we come to item d which is a
notice motion from uh cancer ford again
if if this is
uh approved this will go to the car park
working group and then on to cnr
chair yes declaration of interest
certainly noted thank you
right so with that um cancer four do you
want to
present this one and then i'll ask for a
second yeah yeah um
thanks chair again trying to keep this
brief this unfortunately
i believe you know i don't want to go
negative here but
i'm on the cusp with the the thoracic
council actually honest
we've actually almost become too
friendly we have now made
a car park in a prime site a campsite
it's been totally uh abused whereby you
can't even use a pedestrian access
a lot of time for disabled or young
people with
children in pram now recently there was
even
a fire lit at out of 10 in the sand pit
you know this is beyond the joke
and five pen some of them are not even
paying that because it's not monitored
so
briefly i would like to make this now we
as counselors i know cannot necessarily
dictate
um employees time but in this day and
age for god almighty's sake surely we
could have
flexible working with our enforcement uh
people whatever after all i get up at
quarter four most mornings you know
that's my choice but say six o'clock in
the summer it's not been managed
it's five pound a night they're not
paying it you've got 20 or 30 caravans
it's actually it's not a joke i'm not
laughing
listening to resolving and with that i'm
going to leave it it's a disgrace
thank you do i have a secondary yeah
councillor
thank you chair yes so um this again
this has rambled on for
a few years there's a lot of concern
amongst residents
um about particularly about the
um when it started there were only a few
but
now partly because of people escaping
from lockdown
um there's a huge amount of pressure on
the churchfields car park
um i should actually say that it doesn't
actually mention churchill's car park in
the motion but never mind presumably
people
realised and uh that's
uh i did raise this a year ago with the
car parking officer
and expressed my concern and thought
that there should be a limit on the
number of campervans
but it's it's it has got out of hand now
i think and in fact we've
actually had to provide an overflow car
park in appledore now because of the
pressure so i i fully support this going
to cnr for further discussion
thank you thank you thank you thanks for
watching
his hand up yeah
goes to bushby thank you well yes i
again i was too slow to second uh
council afford on this
i don't know how quick it gotta be my
finger was on the button instantly but
never mind i think it's a really good
notice of motion and i'm
really surprised that hasn't come uh
that our way before because
you know i think it's morally wrong that
the council are in competition with the
local
caravan sites that provide exactly this
facility
there shouldn't be any any motorhomes
overnight
in that car park or any council owned
car park
we're not a privately run facility right
okay yeah so yeah that's that's a
viewpoint which as i say
we will not be debating it tonight yeah
it will be
past the car park working group
i just wonder whether councillor bushby
should declare an interest as he
was running a caravan site at some point
but i know he's not now
right
which member of my family uh coaster
haines is referring to but
at no time have i ever owned had an
interest in
or run a caravan site i apologize chair
um i understood the difference right
thank you
okay let's clear that one up so we'll go
to the vote on this one then please
you do have two other councillors hands
up now
i just wanted to make sure that it's
specific to apple door
the motion well i think that t uh
when it goes to car park working group
the whole issue i think of
uh campervan parking will be will be
raised in it
clearly needs reviewing so
and it's up to the committee then isn't
it the cnr as to
what they decide
all right so the next one councillor
pennington
personal interest chair own a camper van
and enjoy
our apart so got an interest but not a
big one
right well i'm not big
i mean on that basis i own a camera van
but where do you where do you go on that
one you know you have to uh
you know you can't divorce yourself from
the whole of life
purely on that basis but never mind so
we'll go to the vote then
sandra please right thank you chair
council about ten four
councillor brenton dane
sorry was that abstain abstain yes
sorry counselor bright
for chancellor brown
councillor bushby or councillor christie
or pencil clarke or
penciller cottle hankin or
penciller craigie or
councillor ford or cancer gab
abstain chancellor hackett
councillor haims for pencil hawkins
or penciller hicks
okay
for councillor hudson
or pencilla harley or
chancellor inch against
councillor james or cancer
jones or councillor langford
or councillor laws or
cancer leather or
penciller lock or antenna golf
or councillor mackenzie
poor penciller manly or
councillor newton or chancellor
pennington
or pencil watson
and councillor wiseman absentee
27 for one against and four abstentions
chair
thank you sandra as i said at the outset
this will go to the car park working
group before going on to cnr
so uh next item 13 then exclusion
republic
uh publicly so i have to move that the
public being slowly from remainder
meeting because of likely
disclosure exempt information and define
the schedule 12a of local government act
1972. secondary council
council mcgrath is hand up chair wait
yes chair i'd like to second that please
thank you so we move to the vote then
please
thank you chair councillor belton at
four
councillor brenton councillor bright
ball penciller brown or
penciller bushby or pencil christie
or canceler clarke or
chancellor cotton hankin or penciller
craigie
or penciller ford or
chancellor gabb or penciller hackett
paul councillor haims bob
councillor hawkins or
councillor hicks four
councillor hudson or cancer hurley
or councillor inch poor
councillor james or cancer jones
or counselor langford
or pencil in laws
ball pencil leather or
penciller lock or pencil mcgough
or chancellor mckenzie or
counselor manly or chancellor newton
or cancer pennington or
councillor watson or councillor wiseman
or that's unanimous chair thank you very
much well at this point i would like to
say uh good night to the people who are
on youtube and thank you very much for
taking an interest in our uh
debating this evening and uh don't
unless you'll join us again
so uh goodbye to the youtube people
thank you